Meskipun komputer kuantum tidak cocok untuk semua masalah,
ada beberapa kelas masalah
dan potensi penggunaan di mana kita perkirakan
komputasi kuantum akan memberikan dampak.
Itu mencakup simulasi, seperti
pemodelan proses dan sistem yang terjadi di
alam, pencarian dan optimasi
yang melibatkan pencarian solusi terbaik atau
optimal dalam situasi dengan
banyak kemungkinan jawaban, dan matematika
serta pemrosesan data dengan struktur kompleks
termasuk aplikasi untuk machine learning.
Algoritma kuantum mengambil pendekatan baru untuk
masalah-masalah semacam ini, dengan memanfaatkan
fitur unik fisika kuantum seperti
superposisi, interferensi, dan entanglement.
Komputer biasa terjebak
menjelajahi area tertentu dari ruang komputasi
sehingga tidak bisa menemukan pola-pola ini.
Komputer kuantum dilengkapi dengan
kemampuan ekstra atau performa yang lebih tinggi
untuk beberapa masalah berkat sifat kuantumnya.
Untuk benar-benar memahami potensi komputer kuantum
dibutuhkan pemahaman mendalam tentang teori kompleksitas komputasi,
cabang ilmu komputer yang berfokus pada
pengukuran dan perbandingan upaya komputasi yang
dibutuhkan untuk menyelesaikan berbagai jenis masalah.
Ini memberikan kerangka yang berguna
untuk menggambarkan berbagai percepatan
dan kelas masalah yang ditemui dalam
komputasi.